so I'm going to do a video on Super
Mario Brothers Wonder not really going
to be a review as much as just my
thoughts on Super Mario Brothers wonder
why cuz I want to be a little
unconventional about it got to change it
up here I suppose my reviews are just
generally my thoughts so it's not that
different but for game reviews I like to
show footage of me playing the game but
my my capture device just kind of ate
[__] and died so I won't have video game
footage for you on this one also
Nintendo has been notoriously horrible
when it comes to YouTubers using video
game footage of their games and
copyright strike it it's messy it's
really ugly well has been in the past
anyway supp I didn't need both
explanations one or the other would do
so yeah video capture device eight [__]
I want to talk about Mario Wonder so I'm
not waiting to get another one plus if
you know a good one can you comment in
the comment section below let me know
that's right no gameplay footage just
the general UNS soothing nature of my
voice to hold your attention we're going
old school YouTube with this one so
Super Mario Brothers Wonder came out the
same day as Spider-Man 2 and I was like
obviously I'm playing Spider-Man 2 I
knew so many people who were like Mario
Wonder so how you liking Spider-Man 2o I
don't know I'm playing Super Mario
Brothers wonder I was just like he's a
[__] Twilight so after I finished
Spider-Man 2 I was like what else oh
yeah I got Super Mario Brothers Wonder
let me check it out I get it by the way
I get it history will probably not
remember 2023 as the year Mario is just
crushing it with his $1.3 billion box
office revenue for his film and his 2D
platformer which elevated the game of
Mario 2D Platformers nonetheless that is
what happened in 2023 see I played Mario
Wonder at Pax West but it wasn't enough
it was just a demo it wasn't long enough
for me to actually get what the chatter
was about the chatter the hype people
being like it's like Super Mario World
and I was like well yeah there are those
instead of Hills they kind of slanted
platforms of land yeah it's kind of like
Mario World but that's not what the
mario world comparison is as much as
Super Mario Brothers wonder doesn't try
to emulate or be Super Mario World I do
get the comparison that Super Mario
Wonder feels as unique a 2d Super Mario
experience as Super Mario World does see
back when the 2D Mario games were just
what Mario games were Super Mario
Brothers Mario Brothers 3 Mario World so
they did push boundaries they did break
new ground then this is kind of
something the 3D Mario Brothers games
did because Mario games were now 3D then
new Super Mario Brothers came out for
the DS it was a throwback to 2D Mario
games we all love a nice throwback but
the 2D Mario games that have come out
since Super Mario Brothers that Dawn the
new Super Mario Brothers title they
don't feel new they just kind of they
feel like new Super Mario Brothers again
just kind of felt stale and stagnant new
Super Mario Brothers sidescrolling
Platformers were not breaking new ground
they were just kind of living in the
past Super Mario Brothers Wonder changes
all that yes luckily for me there is
still trailer footage that I can and
will use it was readily apparent right
out the gate when I was like all right
what's my time there's no timer that
there's no timer in Super Mario Brothers
Wonder amazing such a simple thing to
remove from a Mario game that just makes
it more enjoyable a timer in a Mario
platform is just a relic of a bygone era
no timer means you get to explore to
your heart's content enjoy being in the
world you're in it takes Mario from
being I got to rush to the flag pole as
quickly as possible to now I'm exploring
and that's just fun to do also the wond
seeds most any level in the game I mean
there are levels that are you got to
take out all the enemies among three
rooms those don't have them but the
levels have these W seeds they're hidden
you get them and something happens I say
something happens because that's the
most accurate description I can give
better phrased I never knew what was
going to happen again that's the
enjoyment I'd find one of these things
and I'd be like here we go I have no
idea maybe the ground's going to turn to
pipes to start doing a wavy thing maybe
I'm going to turn into a blob that
sticks to the ceiling maybe time's going
to speed up maybe it's going to slow
down maybe it's going to do both maybe
I'm in the cave level and you get it and
you're now it's an overhead view in
which you're walking on the background
which changes the entire gameplay
Dynamic Super Mario Wonder goes beyond
the concept of you have blocks enemies
pits powerups and they're laid out in a
2d plane the player essentially has an
obstacle course to get through to get to
the end it's more than that the levels
feel alive with their own Unique
Mechanics the thought was thrown out
there I'd heard the argument do we
really need another 2D Mario game
because with Mario maker and the
collective imagination of the world of
people who have it anything is possible
but now we have Super Mario wonder and
you cannot get that with Super Mario
Maker great soundtrack too that's not
really new for Mario Mario games have
always had great music but the desert
theme in Mario Wonder lives right here I
wake up thinking about it I go to bed
listening to it probably why I wake up
thinking about it I mean you notice from
the trailer and while playing the game
the animations are just they've elevated
the animation when you go down pipes
Mario loses his hat he just grabs his
hat you're the elephant you have to
squeeze down the pipe even taking on the
Goombas the Goombas look at you and you
jump they're like ah you stomp on a
glomba and they kind of freak out cuz
you killed one of their friends you're
not just stepping on Goombas you're
you're stepping on Friends of other
Goombas so when little Goombas are
sleeping I dare say I just jump over the
Goombas and I just let them sleep
they're not hurting anybody and they're
my niece's favorite so you know I let
them live the animations in Super Mario
Brothers Wonder just make the characters
feel like they have so much more
personality it's like Nintendo knows in
order to really make a proper throwback
you maintain the spirit of what came
before but you elevate it in a way in
which new Gamers and old Gamers alike
can feel that feeling experience that
feeling that they did the first time
they played Super Mario Brothers or
their parents felt when they played
Super Mario Brothers look in the end I
remember playing Super Mario Brothers
when I was little and my dad and his
friends my dad who was younger then than
I am
now it's not the gray in my beard that
ages me it's [__] like that but I
remember my dad watching me play and he
was like mushrooms that make you grow
flowers that make you shoot fire stars
that make you blink all the while you're
running on platforms of huge mushrooms
this is a trip Super Mario brother's
Wonder makes Mario for me feel as trippy
as it felt for my parents when they
first saw Super Mario Brothers back in
the day aside from that fun trip Factor
being you know a fun connection that I
made with the game Super Mario Wonder
for me is in fact the most imaginative
2D Super Mario Brothers game and the
most fun I've had in a 2d Super Mario
Brothers game since Super Mario World
that's not even close that is no
question all right so Super Mario
Brothers Wonder have you played it what
did you think about it and seriously a
good game play capture device for
consoles preferably in 4k because the
in-house the onboard PS5 capture well
the colors are just washed out and [__]
so whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see
[Music]
more